let's get into this season Darcy your
Matchmaker Michelle she's phenomenal I
love how she's focused on the inner work
as well as you know the out of work and
dating I wanted to learn how to date
differently her advice is golden you
know she wants to kind of look from
within it kind of also help release past
baggage and it's definitely been an
amazing experience yeah she's definitely
got an amazing clientele and I'm excited
to go on this journey along with her she
knows what she's doing is it gonna work
what can you please well you'll have to
see him find out but I definitely go on
some dates for sure I can't wait to see
well something she brings up is your
filters on your photos
foreign
how would you feel if I showed you a
picture of a guy and he looks so young
and then when you see him he's got right
okay how was that she was very gentle in
the way she called it out but how did
you take that in that moment you know
what hey teach their own I understand
you know I actually was just going
through my scrolling through my phone
when she was asking for some pictures
when I was applying for the application
and those were the ones that I had kind
of most recent they had filters on them
but we ended up doing like a little
impromptu photo shoot in her office on
her phone that were not filtered so we
were able to get some really good shots
of me just in my natural cell right
there is nothing wrong with a good
filter but I know from The Experience
they can kind of get addictive to a
little bit you know but I'm looking at
you right now I'm like if we took a
picture honey
no filter necessary
do you feel that pressure though like
because you're on camera unfiltered
exactly right I just think it's
something that we do for social media
it's fun you know it's my Instagram page
my social media pages and I don't mind
having a filter too I mean you know it's
for fun we are on camera and I'm not
camera ready no hair and makeup you know
yeah a filter just kind of like you see
more of that Airbrush Airbrush Flawless
look there's definitely no shame in our
game yeah filter Queens yeah we know who
we are on the inside and outside yeah
well something else that you opened up
about and I want to get your take on
this too Stacy Darcy you open up about
your experience growing up with your mom
and your dad's relationship and your
fear of being lonely my parents got
divorced when we were 12.
and I don't really feel like I had a
good example to see and know what a
healthy relationship looks like
my mom she never got remarried
she never really dated much after the
divorce my dad even though he's had
multiple marriages they were
not long lasting
I'm sure it affected you know both Stacy
and I and now I just feel like
I don't want to be like my mom
lonely
where are you with that is that still
something that is scaring you or just on
your head your head heavy yeah you know
I feel like coming to Miami single and
ready to mingle you know I have you know
sometimes those thoughts of being alone
not finding the right person but it's
okay it's okay to be alone loving
yourself and you know raising the bar
for who you are as a person and I know I
deserve love
I feel like when the time is right
they'll come to me and there's only fear
and just knowing like you know I don't
want to be like totally alone one day
because I know I can give someone a
beautiful life as well right definitely
going to be in the near future I'm
really excited for it but um yeah I
think in the moment it was a little
fearful it just had kind of moved here
and meeting with a Matchmaker something
I've never really done before so it was
really vulnerable in that moment but
it's okay I feel like I needed her to
open up to me and I wanted to be open to
her as well so when you met this guy
what were your first impressions no it
was like your vibe that you got and I
love how Aspen and Annika were so
excited that we were dating around your
age how old is he
and we're the same exact age yes oh okay
I know they high-fived me and I hide
each other it was really fun to see them
yeah just really happy for me and moving
on and moving forward in my life they're
also very beautiful and smart I am the
most proud mom in the world I love my
daughters they have amazing head on
their shoulders they're super smart
annikos in college she's studying
marketing and wants to go into real
estate you know and Aspen's still
figuring it out but you know she's got
plenty of time in the world and I'm
really excited for what their future
holds I've waited a long time for this
wedding I want it to be beautiful and I
want it to be
a dream come true
you know I I'm just tired of everything
being half-assed and we need to face the
real reason why Florian's cutting
corners
it's time that flooring gets a job all
right Stacy yes let's talk about this
wedding your dream wedding
we're determined to make this wedding
happen yeah as we'll have to kind of
wait and see what happens
but um it definitely turns into you know
a magical moment
to get there but um yeah it's definitely
an epic season of us planning our
wedding so many things happen before and
during and after the wedding so finances
were an issue yep when it comes to the
wedding Lauren's had his green card for
a year now or over a year are we gonna
see him get a job what is he gonna do
um you know
Florian he's very passionate about what
he loves and it's definitely not just
any old job I think he really has a
passion of wanting to start his own
business he wants to design furniture
and open his own Furniture wow sure um
he does love modeling so he wants to you
know dabble on that when he can
um yeah you're just gonna have to is he
a good Punisher designer actually
amazing really yeah so he sketches he
designs everything with his hands he's
self-talk he's self-taught by his dad in
Albania and I've seen his work it's very
intricate and
um it's all just like handmade woodwork
it's he's very talented but what do you
set a fan to bill is a Florian loves you
but they may fear he's taking advantage
of you as well now I definitely don't
feel like Lauren's taking advantage of
me we've been together way too long I'm
pretty sure like you know every
relationship has its ups and downs but
our love is pure it's real and it's true
and
yeah yeah I feel like it's the real deal
and everything in time people that are
closest to us know that it's real love
and he's not taking advantage of me but
yeah like Doris has said things take
time and
you know I've been patient
yeah overly patient but um
you know it's it's kind of hard to
explain I guess you'll just have to
watch the show he's eager for it because
yeah when we're spending time with our
dad he'll give them you know give
flooring business advice so I think he's
in that learning phase right now it's
just taking the action and I feel like
yeah you know we can only guide you so
much and I just feel like he's just got
to take that one step you know and start
and yes even if it's not perfect you
have to start exactly I think he's just
gonna be afraid of failing and but
that's how you learn that's how we learn
yeah you try to tell them that but
right these are two entrepreneurs right
here yeah we give them advice all the
time but he's gotta he's gotta want it
for himself when time is right I can't
do it for him right right and you've got
you found peace filled with that it
seems like you've I feel like we make a
great team regardless and I know
whatever he chooses to do in life he's
gonna be a huge success I really have no
doubts about that well he's lucky to
have you yeah for sure he helps me a lot
yeah in a lot of ways that you know just
with everything you know maybe not
financially but he helps me a lot
oh okay
[Music]